d'accord aucun j'ai écrit trois livres
qui portait sur ce qu'on appelle des
faits divers si c'était pas pour des
raisons de faits divers c'est à chaque
fois il y avait une raison différente
j'ai déjà assez de projets de livres
aujourd'hui pour écrire jusqu'à la fin
de mes jours à bien d'autres acteurs de
cinéma donc dans le film de ces femmes
navy avec la sica davis qui s'appelle
lougarot malheureusement propose d'orgue
d'une chine est en tout cas ou alors
j'ai pas séduit parce que je n'ai pas eu
de proposition pour un autre rôle
j'avais aidé pendant le premier
peaufinant à servir des repas aux sdf
ce qui vient de rien d'extraordinaire ça
se passait dans un hôtel on abriter les
sdf à deux par chambre
sans les avoir testées auparavant sans
leur fournir déjà les savoir-faire des
masses
parce que je m'étais dit c'est que
personne n'aurait mis là ses parents
nous relie à ses enfants
on y serait année dont on m'a toujours
dit qu'une vie humaine ne sont pas
celles du président matheron de celle de
dryden celle de quelqu'un qui vit dans
la rue vallée la même chose visiblement
ne valait pas la même chose
je pense que si on se met à soupeser les
risques les possibilités dans l'île et
les boues éventuelle du public de la
critique ou de la postérité de tous âges
c'est pas con n'écrirai plus long
éclairé mais tout autre littérature que
la mienne
[Musique]
en 2008 vous avez fait un site internet
qui sapait intergénérations tout le
monde interdit que mon ski était à
l'époque un peu trop en avance parce que
les téléphones portables le film et a
donc c'était pas possible de le faire il
fallait un matériel tandis
qu'aujourd'hui ce serait possible
toutes ces paroles qui s'en vont par
exemple des paroles des pères des mères
des grandeurs et des grands-mères et
sont destinés à s'éteindre ses voix
si c'est pas vous qui a enregistré votre
grand mère c'est facile même qui va le
faire ni russie a tout donné
[Musique]